[Musique]
bon attention s'il vous plaît vous êtes
à 8000 km de la grotte et vous descendez
à 11000 mètres jusqu'au plancher
océanique
et vous dans un mois
c'est parti
allez on y va ça va le faire
[Musique]
sur une échelle de 1 à 10 les dégâts
sont combien disent on est descendu
jusqu'au fond océans et on ne sait pas
ce qu'il en est sorti
[Musique]
il faut aller à la station
mais comment tu veux qu'on aille à pied
on est limite en oxygène et on va se
balader au fond de l'océan
c'est parce que c'était quoi ça et tu as
tes projets c'est quoi ce truc
il ya quelque chose qui me suit
[Musique]
j'avais pas
oublié de vous montrer ce que j'ai
trouvé ce matin observez les grands
requins blancs dans leur habitat naturel
incroyable pour les touristes a vraiment
qui passe de la journée sur un bateau et
vous emmener dans un super endroit qu
aucun touriste ne verra jamais en 100
ans
mais comment t'est arrivé à découvrir
cet endroit
on y va
[Musique]
ok allumé volant sacha défaite risque de
pas pouvoir passer à dieu ni que j'en ai
moi ambre l'entrée et au pied des
marches en bas vous êtes traité pire
c'est vraiment débile c'est quoi ça une
alarme d'urgence
une sortie face au courant
non
qu'est ce qu'on va faire on n'a pas le
choix va pas devoir plonger à l'eau et
on doit être la pire ennemie bbc
je suis pas du tout
c'est vraiment l'oreille
hu
et tu sais quoi tu attends je me disais
que je pourrais peut-être sortir un
disque du move your tu as été chanteur
taille des danseurs des jo c'est
vraiment dur de percer
je ferais n'importe quoi pour y arriver
j'ai mis au point un nouveau personnage
on m'appelle de l'émail tu es pour
baiser ces [ __ ] je fais pas dans le
lard tu as fait quoi tes cheveux tu as
l'air d'un maquereau comme ça tout est
mascarade je viens de créer un
personnage sacré numéro tire ma tignasse
où je rêve ouais une perruque c'est ça
je ferai tout ce que vous me demanderez
peu importe ce qu'il faudra faire pour
que cet album explose les charmes c'est
dégoûtant mais sache que tu as un
produit que tu peux ni vendre ni
promouvoir toute ma vie les gens m'ont
dit non on me dit parfois nous rêve
devienne pas réalité monsieur si le cac
est la porte au nez
je trouvais une autre porte je veux que
le monde sache que j'existe ça ne fait
même pas rien et on fait ça il ya même
pas à franges là dedans
si je peux être sous les feux des
projecteurs avec mon propre fils je
pourrais être partout en même temps on
doit mettre de l'émail sur grand écran
quand je vous regarde je vous trouve un
peu plus en cher que les autres plus en
cher
regarde assez dur vu marty ce que je te
propose à toi c'est d'avoir un rôle dans
mon nouveau film tu t'es dit d'aller
pointer devant moi et aller faire
affaire non est si je te laisses et des
risques quand on raconte une histoire
il est toujours préférable d'écrire sur
ce qu'on connaît absolument rien à
raconter sur ma vie ma vie c'est la nuit
c'est les clubs les propriétaires les
gangsters les proxénètes et du couple
tu fais du karaté non mais j'apprends
vite je peux apprendre comment découper
un [ __ ] car action
les maïs et tooway opale toiture ses
droits à tout le monde qu'il est une
bête de sexe
je me demande sur quelle planète il dit
si ce film est un flop tu vas bosser
gratuitement pour tout le reste de ta
vie
je suis extrêmement reconnaissant de
m'avoir fait participer à ce fait j'ai
jamais vu une personne qui me
ressemblent dans les films qui passent
sur caen terrain
[Musique]
dieu donne et mike groupe et c'était
aussi bon que dans sa vie
[Musique]
il vous faut autre chose comment aller
au cottage de belles bergdahl est gentil
propriété d'accord vous arrivez des
états unis je parie qu'il ya une
histoire fascinante derrière votre
voyage quand j'ai perdu mon travail et
mon petit ami à san francisco j'ai
essayé gagner un hôtel vous avez gagné
un hôtel en nouvelle zélande et après un
vol de treize heures jusqu à auckland et
3 tu ce différend je suis désolé je
paierai s'il ya besoin de réparations
avec ça c'est pas très bon pour les pare
chocs
je suis propriétaire d'un hôtel de
charme
on ne peut jamais faire confiance à une
photo de profil sur internet vous avez
vous avez vu un fantôme une chèvre
gilbert c'est un petit futé vous
connaîtriez pas quelqu'un en ville qui
fait des rénovations jacques delors
vidal et son numéro et jack c'est quoi
ton numéro
pourquoi tu en as besoin c'est pour
elles pas dites moi pourquoi vous voulez
mon numéro suis venu vous faire une
proposition et c'est une vraie beauté
si vous voulez je peux vous aider à le
remettre en état sérieusement tu vois
c'est trop vieux et est entré qu'en fait
les vieilles maisons
j'ai toujours été un passionné de
construction sa mère aime sortir dix ans
- cassé blog j'ai l'impression que les
célibataire le plus en vue de beechwood
d'armes c'est un petit faible pour vous
une vraie beauté
oui c'est clair
laly tchad jazz devine quoi j'ai un job
parfait pour toi
la vraie vie maintenant retourner oui
j'oubliais votre avis tu sais ce que je
crois moi que tu lui a pas dit ce que tu
ressentais forêt
régime que l'univers un plan pour chacun
d'entre nous je préfère croire que ça
c'est bien fini
je croyais qu'on était un ami
[Musique]
parle-moi de ton passe temps
on passe alors d'accord est en
permanente aboyer vous et moi j'apprends
à cames
la course est pas un passe temps
quant à moi j'avais pris ma décision
la corse c'est pour moi
[Applaudissements]
j'ai parlé à bob links qui aujourd'hui a
beaucoup de talent mais oui tout sert à
rien parce que tu as de la mer man il
aura une nouvelle voiture l'an prochain
il veut que la pilote pour lui soit des
gestes que ton père m'a dit me fiche
complètement de ce qui peut bien dire je
veux devenir un champion mais ça sera
pas possible si je cours pour non pas le
belge avait plus important que tu ton
propre père j'ai pas fais de toi ce que
tu es pour que tu finisses comme ça tu
es fréquentes lui la clique qui
l'entourent qui laissera très vite et
plus grands le lien familial autre
superstar locale sam la légende malraux
je voudrais être le premier à vous
souhaiter à nouveau la bienvenue n'ai
pas peur de faire frotter débraient
devenir l'enjeu ni d'ambition
ce qu'on peut savoir ce qu'il se passe
entre vous et votre fils carré fils
souvent opposés les uns aux autres dans
les courses plutôt inhabituel
ce qui tu mets ton père dans tous ses
hits il n'y a pas qu'à lui que ça arrive
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
reculé 8e reculer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toujours tu sais je veux que tu reviens
d'hermann
il prendra bien 7
ce que ce soit toi qui pilote qui mieux
que toi elle plus à même de perpétuer la
légende des normes des sérieux sérieux
comme jamais
ok
[Musique]
au revoir le cabinet en voir l'écran
voir les emmerdeurs enfin la famille on
parle on va aller au portugal
papa maman vous n'êtes pas vieux c'est
vrai juste jeunes depuis plus longtemps
que les rats daf il va te prendre pour
une auxiliaire l'éducation à la situe
dit oui une fois c'est mercredi tous les
jours
des chansons
en face à tous les mercredis tu vas y
c'est à forlan et toi pareil depuis ce
matin j'ai c'est que vous appelez il
faut quelque chose d'à fort combat
laquelle tu habites lycée chérioux
il faut pas qu'on m'en parle mais
tempère il arrive que regarder plus tard
de l'incontinence lassoued à personne je
raccroche vie ton père me demanda
bassine change pas les plans par
s'installer au portugal je suis peu trop
serein avec maintenant que je vais
partir
j'ai connu des gens mourant qui mettait
dix ans à mourir pour ma mère
je suis très inquiet ouais je vois que
vous examinez
enfin je suis pas sa mère la retraite
et c'est l'un des membres les plus beaux
de la vie ont pas rater ça
mon fils a pris sa retraite et six mois
plus tard bim crise cardiaque en même
temps il avait 61 ans
vous avez quel âge ou 70 vous avez déjà
bien profiter quand même